House Democrats and even some
Republicans are angry over the sudden
firing of their longtime chaplain by
Speaker Paul Ryan now in questions are
being raised about why it happened ed
O'Keefe reports those opposed no
Congress argues all the time about
almost everything on Friday it chose to
fight about of all things the House
chaplain is it correct that the chaplain
is elected by the whole house just over
ten days ago father Pat Conroy abruptly
resigned Conroy says he was forced out
by Speaker Paul Ryan loving and gracious
God with a 67 year old Catholic priest
has been chaplain since 2011 delivering
the morning prayer before each session
in November he said this during the
debate over tax reform may their efforts
these days guarantee that there are not
winners and losers under new tax laws
but benefits balanced and shared by all
Ryan told fellow Republicans Friday
Conroy's ouster had nothing to do with a
specific prayer but rather because he'd
heard complaints Conroy was not meeting
lawmakers spiritual needs Democrat Gerry
Connolly is just one of at least 150
members in both parties asking Ryan for
a better explanation
Republicans Peter King to be the first
house chaplain in the history of
Congress
the term raises serious questions and I
think we deserve more of an explanation
like for CBS this morning Saturday at
O'Keeffe Capitol Hill